um it is quite a hefty
rise today uh in the numbers how
concerned should we be
i think we should be uh moderately
concerned uh i'm one of those numbers uh
at the moment and if i needed reminding
which i don't really i was a a wet
weekend with eight friends uh six of us
have become
infected so far so a real reminder about
how transmissible this virus is
it's causing cold light symptoms it does
that for the majority that's what it's
been doing for me
thankfully the vaccination rates
or vaccine and having had prior
infection is still protecting us from
severe infections still protecting us
against hospitalizations and increases
in death rates
but it's not protecting us against just
getting infected and that's what we're
seeing in these figures now
they're not a surprise they've been on
the rise the week before and i think
countries in europe are seeing similar
rises
it's interesting you're saying that the
vaccines are still protected against
more severe infection
do you expect as the case numbers tick
up hospitalizations to follow with the
usual lag
i think hospitalizations will increase
just because of the numbers of people
that are being infected you know if
we're talking about 1 in 60 people in
the country are being infected then
that's automatically one in 60 people
who go into hospital at least have got
covered kovid
up until quite recently well and still
the case is more of people have got
covered as an incidental finding in
hospital rather than them necessarily
being there for the primary reason of a
coveted illness uh and i think that will
largely stay the same um there's
evidence that the
omicron variants that we're seeing so
far do cause a milder illness certainly
than the delta virus that we've seen
before
i'm interested to try and unpick uh what
is causing the rise in cases is it
wading immunity is it the fact that
we're all just socializing and mixing
more than previously or is it because
the uh two omicron variants that we've
seen more recently are just more
infectious
uh i think that's probably a combination
of all those things uh it's certainly
the case that with the new variant
people's immunity is not protecting them
against being infected
with every new variant
it's able to evade the immune system a
little bit
and so it allows us to get infected and
in the setting of generally people's
awareness uh you know covert has dropped
out the news quite a bit recently for
understandable reasons uh and i think
certainly in the summer and people being
and meeting again so i think the
combination of immunity waning
and because of people mixing and getting
together those two things
are what's driving that increased rate
do you think that we should start uh
considering i guess some of the
preventative measures that we saw
uh previously i'm thinking about you
know things like uh limiting our social
interactions mask wearing or actually is
are we now at a time when look we're
just having to learn to live with kovid
and if there's no sign that this new
variant or is
more is more severe then we should just
get on with it i guess
yeah i think we're taking the route of
the latter but what people do need to
know if that you know if it is bad for
you to get covet
for example if you've got a health
condition or if you live with someone
who's vulnerable or you really don't
want kobe just before you go on holiday
then doing some things to try and
prevent you from getting infected so
avoiding large crowds wearing a mask on
public transport making sure you're up
to date with a a booster vaccine if
you're eligible for one
just to prevent you getting you know
significantly ill
where i think the effect is going to be
is not so much hopefully the deaths and
hospitalization rates but the effects on
workers because certainly for doctors
and nurses getting covered they can't go
to work you've heard about gatwick
reducing their flights because of the
impact on staff so staff who work in
public facing roles if the infection
rates go up that's where the wider
public are going to start noticing uh
disruption
i just wanted that we've certainly seen
the disruption i have to say um one
other thing uh well i've got you kind of
non-covered related or linked to code if
you like
it feels like we're seeing maybe this is
you know anecdotal but uh increase in at
people going into hospital or people
children catching
respiratory or other viruses at this
time of year which is does feel a bit
strange with the kind of summer months
is that do you think because of a lack
of immunity to viruses because of the
isolation that people were experiencing
during covid is it a real thing
uh it's definitely i mean covid is
certainly with the numbers we've just
seen cobot is still dominating but i
think you're right that there are other
viral infections out there uh you're
also right that because we've been so
good at isolating and wearing masks then
the numbers of infections of other
viruses we've seen over the last two
years has really plummeted so we will
have lost a little bit of immunity
uh to those types of viruses
so i think yes you're right we are we
are in a living now
with more viruses particularly covid but
some of the other things as well and
learning to learning to live with them